A “panacea” is defined as a remedy for
all difficulties and diseases.
It is a medicine, potion, or other item that
can pull a patient back from the brink of
death and save someone from even the worst
of circumstances, a “cure-all.”
It’s a wonderful idea, one that would save
countless lives, put a stop to untold, needless
suffering, and improve the human experience
on a permanent, global scale.
Unfortunately, anyone claiming to have the
solution to all problems is likely just trying
to sell you something.
Unless, of course, that person works at the
SCP Foundation.
Then, they just might be telling you the truth,
because they just might be telling you about
SCP-500.
SCP-500, also known as The Panacea, is completely
unassuming in appearance.
All it consists of is a small plastic pill
bottle, filled with exactly forty-seven red
pills.
This is all that remains of the world’s
only known miracle-cure.
When the pills were first discovered by the
Foundation, they were used in a variety of
experiments in order to determine the limits
- if any - of their curative powers.
They tested the pills on everything from diseases
like cancer to physical injuries like a broken
femur.
In each and every case, one pill taken orally
cured the test subject of all symptoms within
a matter of hours.
After determining that SCP-500 could treat
natural ailments, the Foundation’s scientists
decided to apply it to more unnatural ills.
Two pills were authorized for use with SCP-008,
to be administered to Class D personnel who
had been exposed to it.
At the time of this experiment’s approval,
there were 57 pills in the can.
SCP-008 is a complex prion, or a misfolded
protein with the ability to change the shape
of correctly formed variants of the same protein.
Prions are considered to be the cause of Mad
Cow Disease, among many other debilitating
neurodegenerative diseases.
SCP-008 is no exception to the devastation.
It takes what is terrifying about other prion
diseases, the loss of cognition, the onset
of dementia, the certain death, and cranks
it up to 11.
20 hours after the onset of symptoms, the
infected person will slip into a coma, but
that is not the end of their suffering.
The nervous system is damaged and the cells
have begun to necrotize, but the infected
person is still able to move.
They shamble around on two legs, they crawl,
they grab, and they bite.
They seek out stimuli that indicate the presence
of a living, uninfected human, and they will
attempt to devour it.
The only way to stop an infected individual
is to completely destroy their brain.
Essentially, it is a zombie plague.
Understandably, the Foundation has a vested
interest in curing and containing SCP-008,
and so the promise of the Panacea was an enticing
one.
For the purposes of the experiment, a member
of the Class D personnel was randomly selected
and exposed to SCP-008.
Within three hours, he began to exhibit symptoms,
running a fever of 105 degrees and coughing
and vomiting uncontrollably.
Wanting to see if it would be possible to
use SCP-500 as a cure even in the latest stages
of the disease, the scientists conducting
the experiment allowed the symptoms to progress,
with the test subject eventually slipping
into a coma.
Once comatose, the cell degeneration quickened,
until he began to move again.
His dull, unfocused eyes roamed around the
room, and he lurched toward a member of the
research staff, biting down on her arm.
Of course, she was clad in Hazmat gear in
order to prevent infection, but the Class
D no longer had the cognitive capacity to
understand that.
The researcher seized the opportunity to wrench
his jaws open and stuff one of the SCP-500
pills down his throat.
Once the pill had been swallowed, she vacated
the room and the test subject was quarantined.
After two hours, the research team returned
to investigate the results of their test.
What they found was something amazing.
Sitting in the cell was a completely lucid,
healthy, if a bit confused, man with no signs
of the disease that had previously ravaged
his body.
The Panacea was able to cure SCP-008, even
at its most advanced stages.
So, they knew that SCP-500 could cure a prion
disease like 008, but what else could it cure?
What was the extent of its marvelous medical
power if any?
Could it cure an ailment with virtually no
basis in modern medical understanding?
Next, one pill was approved and allocated
for testing with SCP-409.
SCP-409 is a rock formation resembling a large
quartz crystal.
It is kept in a sealed granite case, and no
one is permitted to touch it with any substance
other than granite, unless during active experimentation.
Anyone who comes into physical contact with
SCP-409 suffers a peculiar, and nightmarish,
fate: they will immediately begin to crystallize,
their body effectively turning into rock.
The crystallization occurs at a rate of roughly
one inch per minute, and will continue until
the victim’s entire body, inside and out,
has solidified.
It is an incredibly painful process, and thought
to be completely irreversible.
Subject 409-D5 was chosen at random from a
group of Class D personnel as the guinea pig
for the next SCP-500 experiment.
He was exposed to SCP-409, touching it with
his index finger.
This small touch was more than enough to seal
his fate.
Upon contact, the finger immediately began
to crystallize, spreading up his hand, his
wrist, and his arm over the course of several
minutes as he screamed in agony.
It was difficult to administer SCP-500 with
all of the screaming, but a researcher was
able to close his mouth long enough for the
pill to be swallowed.
Within a few hours, the Foundation researchers
watched as the crystallization process slowed,
and then stopped.
After nine days in a Foundation hospital ward,
the crystallization process had completely
reversed, and the man was returned to normal.
He still reported phantom pain in the formerly
crystallized parts of his body, but even that
cleared up after several more days.
After the incredible success of the SCP-008
and SCP-409 trials, the Foundation was desperate
to synthesize their own version of SCP-500.
A multitude of experiments were performed
in an attempt to isolate the active ingredient
in the pills, but every time they found what
appeared to be the miracle aspect of the anomalous
pills, they found that they were unable to
synthesize it and have it produce the same
results as the real thing.
Extensive drug trials were conducted, leaving
a trail of injured and dead D Class Personnel
in their wake.
With the traditional pharmacological route
eliminated, the Foundation decided to expose
some of the pills to a variety of other SCPs
in an attempt to somehow recreate or amplify
their effects.
Most of the results were lackluster or completely
uneventful, however, some did yield notable
results.
One pill was taken from SCP-500 and placed
inside of SCP-914, which is a large clockwork
device with a multitude of settings - ranging
from Very Fine to Rough - that is capable
of transforming matter in various ways.
The pill was run through SCP-914 on the “Fine”
setting and the machine produced a small,
silver locket, which would later be classified
as SCP-427.
SCP-427 retained some of the healing properties
of its original form, able to regenerate damaged
cells and purge infection from the body when
it is opened and exposed to a living subject.
During testing, it was able to cure the common
cold in a matter of minutes.
However, unlike SCP-500, the locket produced
notable negative side effects.
Prolonged exposure to SCP-427’s healing
properties increased cell regeneration and
the optimization of bodily systems beyond
a healthy threshold.
Exposure for more than an hour turned the
test subjects into shapeless masses of tissue,
nicknamed “flesh beasts”.
These flesh beasts are highly aggressive and
will attack anything in sight unless they
are put down.
SCP-427 was intended to be a potential replacement
for SCP-500 once the limited number of pills
ran out, but the potential risks of its use
have led to it being shelved indefinitely.
With all attempts to create a different, yet
equally effective version of SCP-500 ending
in failure, the Foundation instead tried to
find a way to duplicate it.
In one case, an experiment was conducted with
the intent to produce more of the Panacea
pills, not using chemistry and compounding,
but instead opting for a much more unusual
method.
After a request was submitted and approved,
five pills from the bottle were selected to
be exposed to SCP-038.
SCP-038 is a highly unique plant, resembling
a common apple tree.
However, it can grow far more than just apples.
The tree can clone any object that touches
its bark, producing the clone on its branches
where an ordinary tree would bear fruit.
The five allocated pills were touched to the
fabric of the tree, and sure enough, clones
of the red capsules began to sprout within
seconds.
But while the tree was able to clone pills
that looked identical to SCP-500, their effectiveness
was sorely lacking compared to the originals.
Cloned pills were only approximately 30% effective
in curing the infections they were used to
treat, as opposed to the 100% effectiveness
with the real deal.
The cloned pills were set aside for treatment
of less severe infections, and all of the
originals were returned to their storage container.
Well, almost all of them.
As the experiment was wrapping up, a D-class
participating in the experiment managed to
pocket one of the five pills allocated for
the test.
The pill’s absence was not noticed until
the following day, at which point it had already
been ingested by the thief.
When interrogated, the man admitted that he
had stolen the pill in order to cure a particularly
nasty hangover, after his usual method of
pickle juice, a bacon sandwich, and aspirin
had failed.
The employee was promptly terminated, and
security around SCP-500 was tightened significantly.
Following this incident, no personnel below
Level Three were permitted to handle SCP-500
in any capacity.
When it was initially brought into the Foundation,
there were approximately 57 pills in SCP-500’s
container and currently, only 47 remain.
Due to the limited amount of pills, and inability
thus far to duplicate them in an equivalently
effective form, experimentation with SCP-500
has been drastically limited.
Most requests for experimentation or allocation
of pills are promptly denied.
These requests have included a Dr. Gibbons
who asked that two pills be given to him for
his personal medkit, as well as a proposed
experiment involving SCP-253, a group of cells
which bear some strong resemblances to cancer.
Several concerned personnel at the Foundation
have worried that SCP-500 may have another
anomalous effect, that it may cause obsessive
fixation in those who spend a great deal of
time with it, leading them to experiment with
it again and again, unable to let it go until
they crack an unsolvable code.
This has been immediately dismissed as trivial
and unfounded by the SCP-500 research team,
surely their obsessive work with the pills
is their own choice, but perhaps the concerned
parties have a point.
After all, there are few things more compelling
than a miracle cure and there is arguably
no greater scientific discovery that could
be made, no higher mountain that one could
climb.
And there is nothing more maddening than having
that life saving pill in your grasp and watch
the number dwindle down one pill at a time,
like grains of sand slipping between your
fingers.
With only 47 pills left and no way to recreate
them on the horizon, perhaps the Panacea is
both a blessing and a curse, a tantalizing
glimpse at what humanity could have but will
never truly achieve.
But hey, maybe they’ll crack the code if
they just try one more experiment, and why
not try?
There’ll still be 46 left… and then 45…
and then… well let’s just hope they figure
it out before they truly are all gone.
Now go check out “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster”
and “The Eye Pods - SCP-131” for more
helpful anomalies!